hey guys P here since history has taught
me that regular preview videos don't do
well in weeks where the whole episode
leaks in advance and since I won't do
videos and episode six before it
officially airs I've been wracking my
brains for an interesting video to make
I looked around at what people are
talking about there was a related
episode 6 looked around in the usual
places on Reddit and Amino and then I
came across some John Targaryen denier
threads so got me thinking about this
dynamic that's in place for what is the
last Targaryen when she first met John
Daenerys pointed out that she was the
last Targaryen and that his ancestor
Tauron Stark
the king who kneeled or the king who
knelt had sworn fealty to her family for
perpetuity most of us chuckled to
ourselves at this in much the same way
we did when the dragon flew over his
head just as the you know at that moment
when he said he wasn't a stark this is
because last season the r plus l equals
j theory was finally revealed when bran
travelled with the three-eyed raven to
the tower of joy there we learned that
Rhaegar Targaryen was John's father and
that Lyanna stark was his mother as she
was dying in that scene now just in case
it wasn't clear
HBO posted this infographic which they
added it on their making a game of
Thrones website like they do with each
episode they had some interesting things
that went into making the episode and it
looks kind of confusing but John's is
really simple there's three lines that
come out of it one says Guardian and it
goes to Ned Stark the other two lines
are parents and one goes to Rhaegar
Targaryen and the other one goes to
Lyanna Stark so there really wasn't any
confusion after this point now people
still just like the idea that that's his
parents because they had a different
theory or they wanted to be a different
way but a lot of the denier stuff you
see is just that people don't like how
the story turned out based on their
prior beliefs I guess but there is no
doubt in the show it's canon that those
are his parents
so what does this actually mean while
John is the king in the north and there
is an outside chance that some of the
people who were behind him there might
not be behind them if they knew you was
a Targaryen I don't think that's an
important part of the dynamic what is
important is that in the last episode
Gilly discovered that Rhaegar had
annulled his marriage to Elia Martell
and that he was Wed to someone else in a
secret ceremony this someone else is
obviously Liana and the fact that the
show is going with the idea that they're
actually married means that John is a
rightful heir to the Iron Throne based
on the Targaryen lineage and the order
of succession because of that line of
succession he actually has a better
claim to the throne than Daenerys does
so I'm going to talk about why that is
the normal line would have been the Mad
King Aerys from him it goes to Rhaegar
because that's his oldest male child in
the case that Rhaegar died and he didn't
have any children then it would go to
Viserys which we know from the show that
was dent Daenerys his older brother and
then if he died and what he did then
Daenerys becomes the rightful heir
however since Rhaegar had children
before he died and john is the last
remaining of those he's actually next in
line before Daenerys so at one point
Viserys thought he was the rightful heir
to the Iron Throne after he was out of
the picture than Daenerys thought she
was this is all under the pretext that
Robert is a usurper though you have to
remember that if Robert's rebellion
never happened and he never took the
throne for house Baratheon that's how
things would have played out of course
in that scenario elyes children wouldn't
have been killed and they would actually
have a stronger claim before John based
on how the whole annulment thing goes
down and there have been a lot of talk
about how this annulment whether it's
legitimate and all these different
things or if it would have really
happened according to the author george
RR martin an annulment can be put
forward by either party it's not exactly
the same
is what we might know from our own
history but you can make it work in the
context of the story it doesn't make a
whole lot of sense but let's just go
with the idea that they would have
brought this up in the show if that's
not what they intend if they did intend
for it to be important so what does this
actually mean well it does it might not
mean anything for a couple of reasons
one reason is that it may never come up
the idea of who's going to sit on the
Iron Throne may become unimportant to
the endgame since we know that there's a
battle going on for humanity's existence
with the White Walkers it also might not
matter if John decides he doesn't want
to sit on the Iron Throne but that's not
as neat and clean as you might think he
didn't necessarily want to be the Lord
Commander of the Nights Watch but he
ended up being that he never really
wanted to be the king in the north but
he is the king in the north so instead
of just looking at John as a reluctant
hero or a reluctant leader who would
never want the throne he's he's the kind
of guy who does what he thinks is best
so people got behind the idea that he
should be on the throne rather than
Daenerys then there's a very good chance
that he might get behind that idea too
and since a lot of people in the story
are worried about Daenerys becoming like
her father that's a very real
possibility based on helping you know
people finding out what his true
bloodline is now the question beyond
that is who actually knows about John's
parents well bran saw the Tower of joy
he was shown that by the three-eyed
raven and there's a good chance that now
that he's going in and looking all this
different stuff he would have found out
by now who John's father is you know I
mean like that seems like an important
part of any information I've thought for
a long time along with a lot of other
people that bran would be the one who
would end up telling John they haven't
seen each other for a long time but
eventually their paths are going to
cross again of course he brought up the
idea that Gilly has seen this
information we don't know if that's
going to come back up in that sense so
she doesn't actually know who they are
Littlefinger may know there has been
little clues that he
might know the actual truth about
Rhaegar and Lyanna but he would have to
have a good reason to put it out there
then we also have the last remaining
person who was present at the tower of
joy in that Talyn read Mira's father
he's long been a mystery about where
he's going to come back into the story
and the show may very well not bring him
back in at all but we saw me or leave
this season to go home so that could
come up and personally I hope it comes
up I hope hallory comes to tell the real
story but we really don't know because
other than the flashback he hasn't
played any real role in the TV show
there's also the Crips as well before
the show that's where it's at in the
story there's always been theories about
important things being inside the Crips
that could reveal John's parentage and
the characters do seem to spend a decent
amount of time down there but I feel I
feel like if that's going to come into
the story at this point it's probably
going to be through brand saying that
there's something there that they're
going to find like it's not just going
to happen organically if you know what I
mean so what if we think is going to
happen whenever Daenerys who believe she
is the last Targaryen and the person who
is destined to sit on the throne
actually finds out that she her claim
isn't as good as John's as it stands now
they don't know they're related and
they're clearly falling for each other
most people agree now that there is a
relationship in the future for these
people but at some point they're going
to find out that she's his aunt could
this whole thing be figuring into that
because if she believes that she should
be there on the Iron Throne as a pot as
a leader of the Seven Kingdoms a ruler
it may be necessary for her to get with
John if he has the better claim like it
sort of rules out the idea of a
political marriage per se like since
they're related but at the same time it
doesn't because in their family this has
happened before and you have to remember
like if you're opposed to this idea of
them getting together that's ok but you
have to remember how this story has been
put together there's not incest in this
story because the author thinks that's
great and that people should do that
he's pointing out all the problems in
this kind of governing in kind in the
patriarchy the the feudalistic dynamic
of if you're the firstborn son you hit
the lottery if you're a bastard you're
nobody you know what I mean like there's
a lot of commentary here about things
that really happen in history they're
not endorsing any of these things
they're just saying that it used to be
like this and look how crazy people got
over holding on to power they would even
marry their own family members you see
so always keep that in the back of your
mind if you're you're having trouble
with that idea in the st. you know in
that way like Daenerys is reasonable to
a certain extent but I can't see her
being like oh okay well this changes
everything I didn't I just you know I
just went through all of this stuff and
got over here to rule the kingdom's but
I'll just give it up to John because
John has a better claim it's very hard
to imagine that happening in the current
climate of what's going down but I do
think that that only leaves door open to
a marriage rather than other things I
mean of course Daenerys could die and
John could sit on the Iron Throne after
the fact but none of the decisions that
they make going forward are going to
involve one of them dying like if this
comes up they have to make a decision on
what to do in light of the information
and in order to get to that place they
have suppose be alive right so I think
my point of view on the whole thing is
the Iron Throne isn't going to matter
but I do wonder how this might influence
their decisions going into the war for
the dawn
as far as dragons are concerned I mean
we all know that John is likely going to
draw pride ragel any time and that would
prove that he has the blood of old
Valyria in him but it doesn't really get
to the bottom of why that is so that
situation brings up more questions and
answers like why are the dragons not
bothered by you I mean Tyrion has been
reading about dragons all his life so
you would think that he would know the
rules of Dragon Riders as much as the
average reader oh the books does so John
hopping on the back would start people
wondering why he's able to do that
because he is the bastard after all
want to know where that blood came from
so I think it's you know it's going to
come out one way or the other the big
question is how does it advance the
story and what do we expect going to
happen once everyone finds out will it
cause a risk or will it lead to a
marriage and there's one last thing that
I want to talk about before I cut this
off and that is that there is another
Targaryen in the books when they say the
last Targaryen obviously there's
Targaryen blood out there in the world
but when they say the last Targaryen or
I'm saying the last our games I'm
talking about ones that are directly in
the line of succession in the books we
have a gun or fake egg on whichever one
you like to call them depending on what
you think and it's interesting because
in the show we have Cersei on the iron
throne which is something I don't think
was ever going to happen there I think
there will be a change of power but
it'll be egg on this it's there and then
Dany has to decide how to deal with this
other person as a Targaryen so they
could be absorbing some of what they
know about the future story from what
George alarm on told them about Aegon
sparked you know because they're not
going to Philly ain't gone on a TV show
so are they absorbing part of that in
the John story it's possible but with
such a short amount of time left I can't
really see things flipping into an
adversarial role like where these two
Targaryen heirs are actually at each
other's throats or at odds so I'm
interested to see what you guys think
let me know in the comments please like
the video if you enjoyed it make sure
you subscribe to my channel if you
haven't done so already follow me on
twitter and my other social media
accounts thanks for watching i'll talk
to you soon